my skin might bleed a lot or be very
scary looking that's normal for me
people might have a second look or say
something under their breath I couldn't
care less my life expectancy was nothing
more than 2 to 5 years but I Breaks the
Rules there's never going to be anybody
like
me I'm danan I'm 43 and I live with epid
demolis Bosa
[Music]
it's comonly known as EB or cotton wool
babies it's a very rare genetic skin
condition I've still got the same skin
as everybody else but it just doesn't
have the binding anchors that hold all
the layers together so any sort of
movement will create a friction type
burn kind of like sandpaper rubbing
against each each
other unable to sort of push the pain to
the background until such times that you
take a step just the wrong way and
you're sort of Frozen in excruciating
pain for a second or
to my version is one of the most severe
versions of
EB the doctors indicated that it would
be better if I passed away sooner or
other than later because the older I
survived the more painful and more
debilitating life was going to
get for a 12-month appointment it was
always marked with an asterisk to call
through and check I was still
[Music]
alive I was the wheelchair bound through
school I needed Tu
feeding it wasn't until I was in my
teenage years that it became prettyy
obvious that I to me I was going to
survive but I I had no real idea what my
future would
hold I found out in the year 2000 that I
was selected to carry the Olympic
torch sport has always been a natural
thing to me I love just about any kind
of
sports I was still wheelchair bound
through those years but I kept sort of
thinking it would be pretty cool they to
walk with the torch I had basically 6
months the physio said it was impossible
my close circle of friends and if it's
something you really want to do you
always work out ways to do it so we got
a treadmill slowly I became strong
enough to be able to stand on the
treadmill and walk on the treadmill and
so literally with about 4 days left I
decided yep stuff it I'm going to walk
with the Olympic
torch I turned up the back street
heading out of kingaroy thinking it
would just be me and my family and there
was basically the entire town was there
to cheer me on it's still one of the
most magical days of my
life it's the first and only time I can
ever recall walking completely
[Music]
painfree in 2001 I was in the best
health of my life I decided to take on
the biggest challenge I could think of
which was moving to Brisbane to set
myself up to live independently didn't
count on all those sort of negative
preconceived ideas of me with a
disability and people in the community
were very scared of me nobody would give
me even the opportunity to give them my
resume and show them what I was capable
of doing
I fell through every crack in the
medical world because I I had then
become too independent to then be classs
being disabled and then I was too
disabled to be independent I moved back
home thinking well that's it I'm just
going to stay in the bedroom and not not
think about having these Grand ideas
that was a really devastating period in
my
life I was at one of my friend's places
it was a few years after the Olympic
torch the two of us got into a
competition to see who was stronger and
I had never done any actual gym
exercises or anything like that and he
said you want to sort of see what you're
capable of doing that first day in the
gym unassisted I lifted my body weight
on the bench press and he we just sat
back in
amazement I'm lucky to be able to
mentally control the pain and then sort
of put mental blockers across it now I'm
classed as one of the strongest power
lifters people have
seen my current record is lifting 150
kilos well over double my body weight
you got
man you show them the video and their
jaws drop and they can't believe
it two years later job opportunities
arose in Brisbane and we move that I've
loved every minute of it since it's just
normal to me that people might have a
second look or say something under their
breath I couldn't care less I break the
mold and there's never going to be
anybody like
me my job these days is as a
motivational speaker from talking to
primary school kids that are dealing
with bullying issues through to some of
the biggest corporations in Australia
and International
I'm really passionate about raising the
awareness for EB in Australia and I
never would have in my wildest dreams
imagined I'd be in this position that I
am
today I hope you've enjoyed my story and
what do we what are we
saying thanks very much for watching I
hope you've enjoyed my story there's
links below to learn more about EB